In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon from a fifth, on which we commemorate the Holy Great
Martyr, Irene.
On the fifth of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Great Martyr, Irene.
In the time of Saint Constantine the Great, King Licinius of the province of Magadon had
a very beautiful daughter called Penelope.
To protect her from all the corruption of the outside world, he had her shut from the age
of six in a high and inaccessible tower, in which she had every imaginable comfort.
Weighted on by thirteen followers, she was taught by a wise old man called Appelian.
One day the girl saw a dove come into the tower holding an olive branch in its beak and
placing it on a golden table, an eagle then came and left a wreath of flowers which it
was carrying in its talons in the same place.
Finally, a black and foul-looking crow brought a serpent and put it there.
When Penelope asked her master the meaning of these things, he explained that she must
receive baptism, symbolized by the olive branch, and that after she had faced trials and afflictions,
she would carry off the royal wreath of martyrdom.
Shortly after this vision an angel came to instruct her in the Christian faith and gave her the
name Irene, which means peace.
After having been baptized Irene threw down her father's idols and phased his threats
with manly resolution.
Licinius furiously had her throne under the paws of wild dogs, but one of them turned on the
king and trampled him down.
Restored to life at his daughter's prayers Licinius was converted, along with a great many
of his subjects, and after having abdicated he retired to the tower where he spent the
rest of his days in tears of repentance.
Cedesius, his successor on the throne, tried to return the princess to idolatry, and in
the face of her obstinate refusal had her throne into a snake-infested pit.
But by the power of God Irene escaped from this trial, as from others that he inflicted
on her and converted many pagans to the true faith.
Cedesius had been dethroned by his enemies, his sons' support went to war to avenge him.
But both he and his army, being struck with blindness, they were unable to move.
Encountering Irene outside the town, they were healed by the saint, but persisted in the
blindness of their souls and put her to further torture, making the young virgin walk three
miles carrying a sack of sand, her feet pierced with nails.
A fronted by this injury done to the saint, the earth opened and swallowed up a large number
of the infidel's.
More than three thousand of the survivors were converted, the king alone remaining inflexible
and being chastised for this by an angel.
Three from then on Irene went through the town proclaiming the good news, and she gained
the greater number of the people for Christ.
She then went to the town of Kalinikun, where having triumphed over the tortures to which
she was submitted, she brought the people including the prefect whom the king had charged
with torturing her to the faith.
The saint's reputation reached king support of Persia, who summoned her and had her beheaded.
But an angel brought her back to life so that she could carry out her mission.
She then went to the town of Mezembria, holding an olive branch in her hand as a sign of
the victory of the faith over all the powers of death.
After having baptized the king of the region and his subjects, she returned to her homeland,
and then went to Ephesus, where she worked miracles worthy of the apostles to support her
preaching.
Having completed this missionary work, Saint Irene took her master Appalion and six disciples,
and going into a newly-huned tomb, ordered them to close it behind her with the stone,
and not to return for four days.
Two days later, Appalion went to the place and found the stone rolled away, and the
tomb empty, from which there comes the belief that the saint had been carried to heaven, like
St. John the Theologian.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.